Lernen ist ätzend? Nicht, wenn man
weiß, wie man am besten lernt.
Sag mal, reicht es nicht,
dass wir ständig lernen müssen?
Jetzt müssen wir auch noch
das Lernen lernen?
Na ja, man kann mit Sicherheit sagen:
Je moderner unsere Welt wird, desto
mehr Ansprüche stellt sie an uns.
Wir müssen ein Leben lang lernen,
nicht nur in der Schule.
Deswegen beschäftigen
sich Wissenschaftler
schon seit über 100 Jahren
mit Lernforschung.
Um herauszufinden,
welche Methoden am effektivsten sind.
Heute gebe ich euch dazu
einen kleinen Überblick,
nämlich die vier häufigsten Fehler,
die wir beim Lernen machen
und wie man sie vermeiden kann.
Wer kennt das nicht?
Die Klausur ist in zwei Tagen,
so ist die nächsten
zwei Nächte nichts mit schlafen.
Wie soll ich denn sonst das alles
hier in mein Gehirn bekommen?
Gut, das grundlegende Problem
ist hier natürlich
das Prokrastinieren,
also das Aufschieben vom Lernen.
Dazu gibt es diese Videos
von uns.
Aber vielleicht
motiviert euch Folgendes,
um das Aufschieben
nicht zu übertreiben, nämlich:
Portionsweises Lernen ist
nachgewiesenermaßen viel effektiver
als viel auf einmal zu lernen.
Wenn ihr versucht, montags
50 neue Vokabeln reinzupfeifen,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass ihr die bis zum Wochenende
vergesst, ziemlich groß.
Besser ist es, jeden Tag jeweils
nur zehn Vokabeln zu lernen.
Unser Gehirn funktioniert nämlich
nicht wie eine Computer-Festplatte,
die mit Daten vollgeschrieben wird,
sondern es ist ein sich
ständig wandelndes Netzwerk,
wo immer wieder
neue Verknüpfungen entstehen.
Und durch kleinere Lerneinheiten
und regelmäßige Pausen
können wir die Bildungen dieser
Verknüpfungen besser unterstützen.
Kleinere Lerneinheiten
bedeuten aber nicht,
dass unser Gehirn
eine bestimmte Lernkapazität hat.
Im Gegenteil: Die Fähigkeit
neue Verbindungen zu verknüpfen,
ist potenziell unerschöpflich.
Und Menschen,
die bereits viel gelernt haben,
fällt es in der Regel leichter,
neue Inhalte zu behalten.
Ich nenne das umgangssprachlich
"Verschultes Lernen",
ohne den Schulen damit
zu nahe treten zu wollen.
Was ich damit meine,
ist das sture Auswendiglernen
von Fakten ohne größeren Kontext.
Wir lernen Grammatikregeln
und Vokabeln auswendig.
Wir lernen Jahreszahlen
in Geschichte.
Namensreaktionen in der Chemie.
Doch das alleine
ist Zeitverschwendung.
Stattdessen lernen wir
am besten durch verknüpfen.
Wenn wir uns klarmachen,
dass unser Gehirn ein Netzwerk
von Neuronen ist,
das sich immer wieder neu verknüpft,
verstehen wir auch, dass wir lernen,
indem wir Neues mit Altem
und Bekanntem verknüpfen.
Anstatt eine Vokabel nur anhand
der Übersetzung zu lernen,
merke ich sie mir viel besser,
wenn ich versuche, mit dieser Vokabel
möglichst viele verschiedene
zusammenhängende Sätze zu bilden.
Und am besten ist es,
wenn ich mir Sätze ausdenke,
die ich so auch im Alltag
gebrauchen könnte.
Und eine chemische Reaktion
merke ich mir viel besser,
wenn ich weiß,
wofür diese Reaktion gut ist.
Und inwiefern sie sich
von anderen Reaktionen,
die ich schon kenne, unterscheidet.
Und wo es vielleicht
Ähnlichkeiten gibt.
Jetzt verstehen wir, warum Menschen,
die viel gelernt haben,
leichter noch mehr Neues lernen.
Sie besitzen schlichtweg
mehr Anknüpfungspunkte,
mit denen die neue Information
vernetzt werden kann.
Und die wichtigste W-Frage
fürs Lernen
ist nicht wer, wie oder wann,
sondern warum.
Wenn wir uns ständig fragen,
warum etwas so ist, wie es ist,
entstehen dadurch
viel mehr Verknüpfungen
und wir lernen viel effektiver.
Sogar, wenn wir keine Antwort
auf die Warum-Frage bekommen.
Ihr habt bestimmt schon mal gehört,
dass jeder Mensch
ein bestimmter Lerntyp ist, oder?
Ich bin ein visueller Lerner. Ich
lerne am besten, wenn ich etwas höre.
Doch diese Hypothese,
nämlich dass bestimmte Lernmethoden
für bestimmte Personen
besonders geeignet sind,
ist bei Experten
weitestgehend überholt.
Höchstens handelt es sich hier
um self-fulfilling prophecy.
D.h., wenn ich glaube, dass ich
visuell besonders gut lernen kann,
fördert alleine mein Glaube daran
bereits die Lerneffizienz.
In Wirklichkeit
ist es am effektivsten,
so variabel wie möglich zu lernen.
Also durchlesen, notieren,
sich laut vorlesen,
sich abfragen lassen,
Tests machen, praktische Übungen.
Je breiter der Methoden-Mix,
desto größer die Lernerfolge.
Übrigens, die beliebteste Lernmethode
unter Schülern und Studenten
halten Experten
für eine der ineffizientesten,
weil sie so passiv ist,
nämlich das Anstreichen
von Text mit Textmarker. Fertig!
Und zur letzten:
Klassisches Beispiel:
Sprachen lernen.
Wenn wir gerade
eine neue Sprache lernen
oder einfach
noch nicht so gut darin sind,
vermeiden wir jede Gelegenheit,
unsere Sprachkenntnisse
im echten Leben zu testen.
Gott, wie peinlich.
Man würde sich ja nur blamieren.
Genau das ist der Fehler,
denn selbstständiges
Reproduzieren von Gelerntem,
also ständig testen
oder testen lassen, ist essenziell,
nicht nur um Neues besser zu lernen,
sondern auch, um es länger
im Gedächtnis zu behalten.
Genauso wichtig ist es, zu wissen,
was man nicht weiß oder nicht kann.
Das hängt mit dem zusammen, was ich
vorhin über den Kontext gesagt habe.
Lasst euch doch mal vor der nächsten
Geschichtsklausur oder Physikklausur
von einem Freund so richtig fies
bis ins kleinste Detail ausfragen.
Wenn ihr erkennt, was ihr noch
nicht wisst oder verstanden habt,
hilft es euch nicht nur dabei,
das Versäumte nachzuholen.
Es hilft euch sogar dabei,
das, was ihr bereits wisst,
besser zu verinnerlichen.
Wenn ihr noch Lerntipps habt,
teilt sie in den Kommentaren.
Ansonsten wünsche ich euch
viel Spaß beim Lernen. Schönschlau.
Untertitel: ARD Text
im Auftrag von Funk (2017)
Über eure Lerntipps freue ich mich
genauso sehr wie über eure Fragen.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt,
die ihr gerne in einem Video
beantwortet haben möchtet,
schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wir sehen uns nächste Woche,
bis dahin: bleibt sicher.